kiev en alerte quasi permanente
l'hypothèse d'une attaque terrestre
russe plane plus que jamais sur la
capitale et pour ses habitants notamment
ceux français restait sur une place des
heures difficiles se profile tout est
prêt les sacs et les documents on a
passé la nuit dans les abris là
une attaque est bon c'est un stress
c'est inimaginable
il est
pour l'heure l'offensive terrestre sur
kiev n'a pas commencé les troupes russes
et leurs blindés sont toujours en
attente au nord de la capitale d'après
ce rapport du secrétariat américain à la
défense publié hier soir ils font face à
une résistance plus importante que prévu
ils ont aussi des problèmes
d'approvisionnement dans de nombreux cas
les colonnes sont littéralement à court
d'essence et elle commence maintenant à
manquer de nourriture pour leurs troupes
malgré ses carences pointé par les états
unis l'artillerie russes continuent de
pilonner kiev et sa banlieue à
borodianka à 50 km de la capitale où ici
et d ailleurs pin en proche banlieue son
sein des immeubles d'habitation été
ravagé par les bombardements
sont en train de déblayer la même chose
pour la tour de la télévision frappé
hier en fin d'après midi
cinq personnes ont été tuées les corps
ont été enlevés que ce matin
les victimes civiles et la violence des
bombardements pèsent sur le moral de
tous les ukrainiens et peut-être encore
davantage chez ces hommes ces femmes et
ces enfants réfugiés dans le métro de la
capitale
non
je vais mal avec cette guerre
ma voisine qui est né en 1934 m'a dit
que même les nazis n'étaient pas comme
ça avec nous
qu'ils aient battant l'attaquent russe
et se prépare dans la ville les ateliers
improvisée de confection de cocktails
molotov se multiplient